Russell Wilson of the Seahawks joining
us on the program
good morning Russ how are you good
morning you guys doing where are you I'm
at the facility right now in Seattle bit
did anybody get there before you I don't
think I don't think so that's why I
don't think so what's the earliest
you've ever arrived at Camp at the
facilities uh probably 4 a.m. this
morning I got here at 4:30 so I'm just
getting ready for this week you know you
know it's gonna be exciting we got a big
game coming up first game of the year so
has the Denver so it's gonna be a good
challenge but looking forward to the
place wait what do you do at 4:30 in the
morning watch film just get prepared
getting assured that the week is ready
to roll and just you know it's a it's a
process you know and you gotta trust the
process you know my thought is I got 16
weeks to doing you know to do whatever
it takes to win you know and so you know
you sacrifice that and get up get up and
get early and early and sounds like you
might be trying to get out of diaper
duty is that any truth to that well the
good thing is the futures potty-trained
and Sienna she's uh she's not too bad so
she's getting there too so I don't have
to worry about it too much okay that's
part of the reason I name is part reason
why getting up early summer vacation you
guys doing anything fun he had an
amazing time we here and I in the family
a tween and we went multiple places we
went we were able to go to London we
went to China I went to Shanghai
Hangzhou and then we went to Mencia and
I you know she and she told me you know
and she you know we've been married for
you know a couple years now she says you
know Russ that little hidest
thing we did you know for that four days
after we got married I don't consider
that a honey man so what do you mean she
just well you know honey my honeymoons
are seven days or more so
yeah I had to level up and take her to
we went to we went to Japan went to
Tokyo and then we flew to went to South
Africa and we went down to Cape Town and
we've got to go around the townships in
Cape Town which was pretty amazing and
just it was just amazing to see so many
young kids with nothing with nothing but
yet seeing the joy on their faces and
just the joy that they have in their
hearts and so much love it was the most
rewarding thing in the world and so to
build a do that and then we went in
Safari and we went to we went to we went
to Botswana we went to Madi Quay so yeah
we saw some lions and we saw everything
animal you could ever imagine pretty
much Wow okay who got recognized more
you were your wife on these trips she
did for sure everybody was jamming to
her music in Africa it was it was pretty
funny so you know she could not she can
move a lot better than me
is it Ciarra or Sierra I thought it was
CR you called her Sierra yeah yeah
Oh Sierra News I've been calling Sierra
[Music]
okay
now I didn't want to offend her there
Russell Wilson joining us by the way on
the cover of Wheaties pretty pretty big
stuff there yeah pretty cool and it
would be I remember and you know back in
the day walking down aisle nine and in
the grocery stores you know Richmond
Virginia and I get a box of Wheaties you
know and seeing guys like you know
Muhammad Ali or or Michael Jordan you
know and John Elway's of the Worlds and
seeing Dan Marino and and then you know
ken griffey jr. that with the backwards
hat you know hitting homeruns you know
those are those are the type of things
that are inspiring as a young kid you
know just to be able to come from
Richmond Virginia small town and just be
able to you know cover of Wheaties it's
pretty pretty amazing
that's the breakfast of champions and so
actually actually surprise gonna be
surprised in future this morning with a
fresh new box if we do so you know he
doesn't he doesn't know quite yet so
he's gonna know what's when dads on the
cover of Wheaties he's gonna look at you
yeah I'm taking it
first day of school today so I'm fired
up to take them and and have some fun
with them today so it'll be cool is he
allowed to root for anybody other than
you yeah of course please he's a
big-time Hawks fan he's like you know
yeah he's chanting around the house go
Hawks
the funny thing is the funniest thing is
though that he now green 80 it's
actually pretty funny and so but he
loves he loves he loves going the games
and just having a good time that's for
sure I I know that you obviously we're
Khalil Mac is now in Chicago Bear and
that that changed a little bit with your
preparation because week two you get to
see Khalil Mac what do you think of that
deal was pretty pretty a great deal um I
mean obviously he's one of the best
players in the game he's he's been
spectacular you know ever since he
stepped on the field and you know he's a
he's a star for sure and you know he's
he's a game changer he makes plays you
know and you know so getting ready for
week one you know was actually on week
one we got on week one and then we got
Clio week two and the rest of the group
so you know but it'll be exciting season
we're looking forward to the journey but
you know Coolio is very very deserving
that's for sure you're gonna run into
three probably the three best defensive
players in the game you got Aaron Donald
you get him twice and you get Khalil Mac
you get bond Miller anybody else you
want to throw in there guys
are you faster than you know you don't
wanna get you don't want to get caught
from behind with you know those guys
running after you but those guys got a
lot of respect for they play the game
tough they play the game the right way
there
you know so you know you know then the
day I'm into my career you know
hopefully 15 20 years from now you know
those guys are going to be Hall of
Famers and to think about you know some
of the guys have gotten to play against
so far in my career it's always fun and
we get to play the dust of the bus is
exciting
you're 29 the 29 used to be old in the
NFL you're 12 years younger than Tom
Brady will you be playing at 41 yes I
will my god willing you know I just for
me you know I've invested a lot in terms
of you know my body and my mind and just
you know just all the things I do all
day every day you know all offseason
there's no such thing as an all day you
know and so you have to prepare that way
and I think that you know how you
prepare is huge and how you how you
prepare to be the best every single time
you step on the field and making sure
that you're here 100% I'm just wondering
about this you went on that Safari if
you were gonna attach an animal to aaron
Donald von Miller and Khalil Mac of the
animals you saw on the safari with
Sierra Sierra what what animal would you
would you attach okay let's start with a
little Mac well three of them for the
most part I would look a lil Mac you
know that's a good one you know I would
say Khalil and Aaron they're they're
more like they're like rhinos man they a
funny thing is we got that we got to the
cool thing is we got to poach you know
there's a lot anti poaching going on
about poaching going on so we for the
anti poaching going on in Africa because
it's none of the time save the rhinos we
were we were trying to help save them so
we are able to we were able to help save
two rhinos and that was pretty amazing
so to be able to get up and close and
personal the rhinos you know and just
you know to you know help take their
blood and help really kind of mark them
so that way when they when when all
these poachers are trying to kill them
you know they can track them and the way
they can find the poachers and help save
help save these rhinos and
so but anyways you know I would say
Aaron Donald and Khalil and even bond
they're like rhinos they're they're
faster they're physical and they can
they can get in and out of break so
they're pretty they're pretty athletic
could you elude a rhino no we usually a
rhino move it's it's it's pretty
incredible I think they go up to like 40
maybe even 50 miles an hour
exactly yeah it's pretty wild oh boy
what do you think of Colin Kaepernick's
Nike ad have you uh have you seen that I
had a chance to really look at it yeah I
saw I saw it this morning kind of I was
I was I was about to hop in the car not
notice that I was talking about it so
but um you know I think the end of the
day you know what you know the thing
that the world really needs then is love
and grace and and you know so much going
on right now and you know I think that
that's just what what we all need right
now you know there's there's so many so
many things going on and we get so
distracted with everything else that we
then we forget to do that you know Matt
if you're white manager black manager
but you know Latino no matter where
you're from you know that's what when
you do a better job of and you know it's
just it's just interesting time I can
say these Russell Wilson he's on the
cover of Wheaties by the way how are my
see hunks gonna look I think it's gonna
be great this year I'm super excited
about our new office acorrea
Schottenheimer and you've done a great
job so far it's been exciting just to
see you know you know Dwayne brown left
tackle you know and have him here for
the whole year to have you know Doug
Baldwin Phil and great Tyler Lockett
looking great we got Brandon Marshall
you know guys clocks 100
no balls you know in his career you know
I've done some amazing things he's a
star and got so many other you know
players and excited about the running
backs too so I think we're gonna be
really good and you know obviously got
you know Bobby Wagner and KJ right you
know I believe that defense you know so
I think we're gonna have a great team
and you know it reminds me of I see a
lot of 2012 and you know and I got to
the Seahawks huh nobody had great high
expectations or anything like that but
you create the great thing about
football is no matter what the critics
say or no matter what people think you
know it's you know you find out between
the white lines you know for 60 minutes
and that's when we get to find out you
know weekend a week out yeah
if this do you get a playoff share from
the Yankees this year you know when I'm
hoping for is that the Yankees win the
World Series because then I feel like
I've been a part of the journey you know
they go to go to training camp and to be
around all that it was that was amazing
I've been a Yankee fans ironically I
being hanky fan since I was a little
little kid but if the Yankees win the
World Series for us will you
go to the parade trying to get away from
me you know Aaron Donald you know
probably that week but just spring
training next year yeah I plan to I'd be
allowed to be a lot of fun I you know
you learn so much you know to be able to
you know you know sit down and talk to
some of the best players to ever play
the game and you know and and and and
you know just be able to do a great job
of bringing you know Hall of Famers back
and all that kind of stuff and just to
be able to sit down with people and talk
about you know what success looks like
and why they've been successful you know
the thing is they have they still have
you know the same the same the same
bottles in the training room you know
for you know for cleaning up your legs
and all that kind of stuff as as they
did way back in the day you know some of
the best players ever play the game it's
it's this idea of the tradition this
idea of
of Champions you know and everybody they
know one of things in savor the Yankees
is once you put on this pinstripes
you're immortal and it's just an amazing
thing and they do an amazing job of you
know a lot of us you know attributed you
know Cashman and what he's done and just
the organization and it's fun watching
those guys playoffs for sure and those
guys can really swing the bat man
watching those guys hit home runs and to
be able to to be able to get to get in
the batting cage and get on the field
with them and take grounders and and
swing away too as well as a lot of fun
that's for sure
he's Russell Wilson jr. the third he's
on the cover of Wheaties please tell CRO
that Ciara that we said hello and good
luck against the Broncos thanks mama I'm
not to see you do the level up challenge
dance that she has been doing that I got
to see guys you got to send me a video
oh wait a minute
okay go get the bill against the grain
but Thank You Russell that's Russell
Wilson jr. that's there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]